it's official tens has signed a
long-term deal
with sentinels in a move that's been
reported to cost
an eye-watering seven figures this comes
on the heels of a truly insane
performance
at valeran's first ever international
land masters 2
held in reykjavik iceland over 1 million
concurrent viewers
tuned in to watch n.a assert its
regional dominance
and it's an incredible story a
substitute player who became the hero
his team and all of n a needed
if you're watching this video but you're
not sub to the channel
it's kind of like you're in a post plant
situation
you might have to commit to take the w
here so why don't you hit that subscribe
button
ring the notification bell and then i'll
bait for you
i'm pretty sure he's ratting in u-haul
so an hour before
this video was supposed to be published
sentinels confirmed the news that
tens the aim god himself had signed with
the organization
long term that means he's no longer on
loan from cloud nine
and according to a report from the
esports observer
the deal is worth a reported seven
figures and while we don't have an exact
number
seven figures is objectively a [ __ ] ton
of money
now if you haven't been following the
story as closely as we have
here's a little bit of a timeline
explaining how tens ended up with
sentinels
originally back in march prior to
masters 1
sinatra was suspended from sentinels
and tens was added to the team on an
interim basis
then they went on to win the whole damn
tournament
tense's interim deal with sentinels was
then extended
once again to include the duration of
masters 2
in iceland and now he's north america's
[ __ ] hero and now finally after
all that back and forth and speculation
about
exactly how much money this kid would
command
it's official tens is a full-time member
of sentinels
after the news officially broke cloud9
ceo jackie tien
commented on a reddit thread related to
the announcement
quote hey to give some context this deal
was done
before iceland it was a dangerous deal
for us as we knew we would soon face
sentinels in the iceland qualifiers
however it was important to tyson to
play and i wanted to make it happen for
him
best of luck to tyson on sentinels end
quote
nobody knew except our manager they told
us after we won
this news comes hot on the heels of the
past two weekends as
reykjavik iceland played host to the
first ever
international land in valorance history
vct masters 2. there was also a league
of legends tournament but i'm not going
to talk about that and if you're an n a
fan you've
probably already blocked it from your
memory heading into this tournament the
biggest question was obvious
which region was gonna dunk on all the
others a strong contender for that title
was a north american
sentinels roster they had to make a
change back in march for vct masters
won when their star player sinatra was
suspended
so they brought in tens on loan from
cloud9
when you have under 48 hours before your
first game with your new team
it's easy to relax your expectations a
bit
but tens absolutely popped off at
masters one
and he's been doing the same thing ever
since so
at vct masters 2 sentinels
swept the bracket without losing a
single map
just use that one frag oh
that as well the dash comes through he's
gonna whiff doesn't matter and coach
shazam
finds another the updraft over the top
here as he tries to find the oh my god
shazam
he's making this one work but even
though they never actually
dropped a map there were some pretty
close calls
in their grand final series against
fnatic which they won
3-0 two of the maps went to overtime and
the third was
extremely close as one of my mutuals on
twitter pointed out
how often do you get a 3-0 that's this
thrilling
34 feels like enough to take a head shot
but he does have 150 and a tap and go is
what he needs
there's the tap oh it's a bounce from
elbow
and he thinks it's from long oh mystic
you
five head man oh my word
what a play i could try to get the
positional information i think they
understand what's going on right now on
fnatic
there comes a spam into the smoke just
on the edge of the smoke wait a minute
wait a minute i don't know where it is
just getting the stick
and that's fnatic picking up the pistol
oh no
sentinels the one was closed they don't
know oh my god he gets less the team
flash
the team flash magnum's in the smoke
here oh my god
magnum's got no hp not like this
sentinels
they're gonna get the defuse they've
done it sentinels
are the masters to reykjavik champions
and they do it flawlessly they didn't
drop a single map
so yeah it was north america's sentinels
hoisting the trophy
at the end of it all and i think i speak
for a lot of fans when i say that
finally settling the n a versus eu
debate has been
extremely satisfying and while tens
certainly popped off at this tournament
it wasn't a solo effort
every member of sentinels came through
big for this roster
and i think special mention should be
made for shazam
who had this team looking like a
contender from basically the moment
tens loaded into his first game this run
is one of the most
unbelievable in esports a stand-in
player becoming the game's icon
his team's secret weapon and yeah the
mvp at a global championship okay so
technically they didn't do finals or
tournament-wide mvps but
i think he can pretty much look at the
stats and come to the same conclusion
but while the question of which team was
the world's best has been answered
there's a lot of other questions coming
up quickly but what about
sentinel's opponents fnatic were the
second seat out of europe
and their play against sentinels was
honestly pretty good
with three close maps it wasn't a
blowout and they easily pushed sentinels
harder than
any other opponent at this tournament if
you can't win
being the most difficult opponent for
the eventual champions
is a pretty good consolation prize durka
specifically
was a massively important part of this
team he earned the daily mvp awards for
three of the six tournament days
and he led the tournament in both entry
kills and multi kills
suggest tucked in on the site has
reinforcements on the way but also has
the power
of surprise durka is left alone the
blade storm pops he's up against an
operator
and connecting every single shot but in
overtime
fnatic couldn't get it done i'm hoping
we get a rematch between these two teams
soon
potentially at vct masters 3 in berlin
assuming that both these teams qualify
another team that didn't quite get it
done at this tournament was team liquid
who were eliminated outside of the top
three after a series against fnatic
but it's not all bad news for tl scream
hit those
crispy one taps throughout the
tournament and actually ended with the
highest adr of any player in the
tournament
beating even tens by 20 points if you're
not familiar with adr
it stands for average damage per round
with so many
what ifs and near misses behind him and
cs go
i think there are plenty of fans who
would love to see the headshot machine
rise to greatness invalorent and i think
liquid can go back to the drawing board
on this one
and figure some things out liquid also
gave us another memorable moment that
i think we're going to be hearing about
for a while it's all about them trying
to bide the time towards a as well
they've got a hinder this approach and
soul cass
the flank's so good here does he decide
to go for this
[Music]
listen riot i'll pay good money if you
can turn that call from pansy
into a voice line that plays for
everyone when i went around
just hit me up but perhaps the most
enduring meme of the event will be
version one's vanity and his cat ears
now exposed to a huge audience that
watched this event
v1 looked like they might be a dark
horse contender at this tournament after
they bumped team liquid to the lower
bracket
but after a loss to new turn gaming they
were ultimately eliminated by fnatic
maybe vanity went through all of his
nine lives but
this performance has put v1 on a lot of
people's radars
and we'll be following them closely
speaking of new turn
their roster featured long-time
counter-strike player solo
who turned 33 this year after a top
three exit from the tournament
solo said that he was considering
retirement
but as a fellow 33 year old just go for
it man
still it looks like the odds might be in
favor of his retirement
another thing that was significant at
this tournament is what some
are calling the post plant meta and
please
don't call it the after plant meta we
already have a term
for it and after plant just sounds
really weird
in any case my experience with the after
plant meta
is ordering onion rings at 1 am shout
out to my local burger place
basically the idea is that with the
right utility you can delay a bomb
defuse for a long time and sometimes
from very safe locations
think silva shock darts viper snake
bites
killjoy grenades astra gravity wells
all that good stuff the bomb timer is
similar to cs goes but there's also no
diffuse kits
so if an attacking team manages to plant
the bomb and they have enough utility
remaining on their surviving agents
then a retake and defuse situation for
the defense
becomes pretty difficult now this meta
isn't necessarily new
it's actually been discussed for a few
months now but it is becoming
increasingly popular and there isn't a
great
counter available to it besides
potentially
sage's wall but that means you have to
keep it for the post plant situation
there are already fans clamoring for an
agent that can deal with utility
as it comes in this doesn't exist in
valorent or
cs go obviously but in games like
rainbow six siege there are operators
like jaeger
or wamai that do exactly that i don't
know what riot has lined up but
some ways to counter this meta would
definitely be interesting
and whether that counter comes from
player adaptation
or specifically developed in a new agent
by riot
remains to be seen so what did you guys
think about the tournament
is tens going to be annihilating the
competition with sentinels for years to
come
is the post plant meta already a problem
and
most importantly when are we gonna get
to see those vanity cat ears again
let me know in the comments below i'm
gonna do my best to have an impression
you're ready
here we go so for the past two weekends
reykjavik
iceland played host to
i couldn't do i could i could i couldn't
maintain i couldn't maintain the devin
tone
i couldn't maintain it i bailed out hard
bro
one of these days i will do an entire
video like this
in the tone of another person at the
score
so if you if you actually get to the end
of this video and you watch this
you tell me which person at the score
you want me to imitate and i
i i'll just take votes and then i'll
just try and do it but this guy
who told me that this was true didn't
even have a username
there you go okay there's a little taste
there's a little taste